la russie peut compter sur le soutien
indéfectible de la chine dans cette
crise je craignais n'a l'occasion de
l'ouverture des jeux olympiques d'hiver
la dîmière poutine se rend aujourd'hui à
pékin des jeux olympiques marquée par
l'absence de plusieurs délégations
étrangères la correspondance de notre de
à moscou demain et les extraits au
lendemain de la rencontre entre le chef
de la diplomatie russe et son homologue
chinois c'est au tour de vladimir
poutine de se rendre à pékin il doit s'y
entretenir avec xi jinping de l'état
actuel et les perspectives de
développement des relations russo
chinoises et deux hommes devraient
aborder la coopération bilatérale
notamment dans les secteurs économique
et commercial énergétique scientifique
et culturel les grands dossiers mondiaux
et régionaux sont également à l'ordre du
jour à ce sujet bladimir poutine est
revenu sur les positions très proches de
pékin et de moscou dans une interview
écrite publiée ce jeudi par le média
chinois china media corporation
la chine est notre partenaire
stratégique sur la scène internationale
nos approches coïncide où sont très
proches concernant la majorité des
questions de l'agenda mondial nous
maintenons une coordination étroite dans
le cadre des principales organisations
et formats multilatéraux tels que l'onu
les brics le cs le g20 l'apec le sommet
de l'asie orientale ce qui a un effet
stabilisateur sur la difficile situation
actuelle dans le monde à l'issue de leur
rencontre les deux dirigeants doivent
adopter une déclaration reprenant leur
approche commune pour résoudre les
grands problèmes mondiaux actuels ces
pourparlers sont la 38e rencontre entre
les chefs d'état depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir du xi jingping en 2013 et leur
premier entretien en face à face en près
de deux ans